[Musique]
l'état libre aux portes de kaboul se
sont emparés ce vendredi deux fois la
larme à seulement 50 km de la capitale
après avoir repris à lashkar gah
kandahar herat grande ville
d'afghanistan les insurgés contrôlent
désormais la majeure partie du temps il
se rapproche donc de la capitale
washington et londres évacuent leurs
diplomates et leurs ressortissants
inquiétude des diplomaties européennes
lauton s'est réuni en urgence
[Musique]
martinique et guadeloupe ont désormais
total sont désormais totalement
confinées pour tenter de ralentir les
arrivées de taxi ont commis à l'hôpital
des patients jeunes en déplacement à
fort de france le ministre de la santé
déplore ce qu'aucun d'entre eux n'ait
été vaccinées en libérant qui évoque une
situation sanitaire tout comme une
mesure aux entier il appelle à la
vaccination des renforts matériels et
humains ont été envoyés sur place
[Musique]
alors été des incendies maîtrisés en
algérie depuis lundi les feux de forêts
ravagent la kabylie dans le nord du pays
s'ils ont fait au moins 71 morts les
appels à l'est se multiplient dans la
société civile en algérie et au delà un
élan de solidarité qui se déploie sur le
terrain environ
[Musique]
non
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france
les villes tombent les unes après les
autres entre les mains des talibans en
seulement huit jours ils ont repris près
de la moitié des capitales provinciales
ces dernières 24 heures ils se sont donc
emparés de lashkar gah dans le futur
quelques heures à pas après avoir fait
tomber et raté kandar deuxième ville du
pays située à 150 km à l'est de la
capitale les insurgés contrôlent aussi
désormais poil à la lame à seulement 50
km au sud de kaboul une prise de la
capitale marquerait le retour au pouvoir
comment réagit la population afghane
écoutez
on est très préoccupé par la situation
en afghanistan parce qu'on voit les
talibans capturés des provinces tous les
jours on veut la reprise des
négociations de paix de doha on veut
voir la paix en afghanistan et la fin de
la violence dans le pays
tous les marchés les magasins sont
détruits beaucoup de gens ont été tuées
pendant ces combats dans le pays je
pense que kaboul est également en danger
des combats sont en cours dans toutes
les provinces d'afghanistan et c'est une
situation de crise le peuple afghans
attendaient et aspirer à la paix ils
n'attendaient pas une augmentation des
combats dans le pays
la situation s'est aggravée partout en
afghanistan si ça continue comme ça les
talibans reviendront aussi à kaboul mais
tout ce que les afghans veulent c'est la
fin de la guerre et la paix
et l'otan s'est réuni en urgence cet
après-midi l'alliance atlantique qui
soutiendra longtemps possible
gouvernement afghan déclare son
secrétaire général l'allemagne et la
finlande d'essayer de réduire leur
personnel diplomatique à kaboul la
norvège le danemark qui ferment
temporairement leurs ambassades
les états unis et le royaume uni et
choisissent de d'évacuer leurs
diplomates et leurs ressortissants boris
johnson a convoqué une réunion de crise
aujourd'hui le premier ministre
britannique promet de ne pas tourner le
dos à l'afghanistan
londres qui redoutent un retour d'al
qaïda
je suis absolument inquiets que les
états en faillite soit des viviers pour
ce type de personne bien sûr que je suis
inquiet c'est pourquoi j'ai dit que
j'avais le sentiment que ce n'était pas
le bon moment où la bonne décision à
prendre parce que bien sûr al-qaïda
reviendra probablement il aimerait
certainement ce type de terreau c'est ce
que nous voyons les états faillis dans
le monde sont source d'instabilité et
constitue une menace pour notre sécurité
nos intérêts nous sommes très clairs à
ce sujet c'est pourquoi l'occident doit
apprendre que l'on ne règle pas les
problèmes on les gère vous devez vous
rendre dans un pays si c'est ce que vous
allez faire et vous devez le gérer il
n'y a pas de solution instantanée et je
pense que c'est l'une des différences
entre l'occident et de nombreuses
régions du monde
oui je suis inquiet mais nous avons les
moyens de nous protéger même après avoir
quitté l'afghanistan
il
est face à la percée des talibans les
etats-unis se voient contraints de
revoir leurs plans washington a décidé
d'envoyer et 3000 soldats dans le pays
pour permettre à l'évacuation des
ressortissants américains on voit tout
de suite notre correspondant à
washington thomas bonnin
thomas bonsoir la maison blanche affirme
qu'il ne s'agit pas là d'un réengagement
militaires
n'ont pas de ré engagement militaire
mais force est de constater que 3000
soldats vont être de nouveau envoyé à
destination de l'afghanistan plus
précisément à l'aéroport de kaboul ils
vont rejoindre les 650 soldats
américains qui sont déjà sur place il
faut noter aussi que 3500 soldats
américains supplémentaires vont eux être
déployée au koweït pour être prêts à
être envoyés en cas de besoin en renfort
justement en afghanistan écoutez les
précisions de ce dispositif militaire
c'est le porte parole du pentagone qui
prend la parole
le premier mouvement sera constitué de
trois bataillons d'infanterie qui se
trouve actuellement dans la zone de
responsabilité du commandement central
des états unis ils se rendront à
l'aéroport international de kaboul dans
les 24 à 48 heures deux de ces
bataillons relève des marines et le
troisième de l'armée américaine
il reste donc une question est ce que le
retrait complet des troupes américaines
d'afghanistan pourra être effectuée
d'ici le 31 août comme initialement
prévu par le président américain à lire
la question a été posée justement au
porte parole du pentagone qui n'a pas
vraiment pu répondre et pas vraiment pu
fixer d'agenda précis pour le retrait
total des troupes américaines
d'afghanistan il ait aussi expliqué que
la chute de kaboul elle n'était pas
inéluctable en rappelant que les forces
armées afghanes étaient plus nombreuses
que les talibans mais il faut bien
comprendre que l'optimisme affiché ces
dernières semaines par les autorités
américaines a été douché par la percée
des talibans en afghanistan ces
dernières semaines avec kaboul donc qui
pourraient tomber aux mains des talibans
bien plus vite que prévu et c'est pour
cette raison que l'évacuation a été
accélérée en afghanistan en tout cas
cette situation attire les critiques de
la part de l'opposition l'a notamment vu
un communiqué de donald trump ou encore
des figures républicaines prendre la
parole pour et bien critiqué la décision
de jordan écouter ils auraient dû
incombait au gouvernement américain de
procéder à une sortie responsable lors
du retrait des forces restant
d'afghanistan mais en quelques mois
l'administration maiden a mené un
processus de retrait bâclé qui a
maintenant livrer un pays entier au
terroir east
alors certains ici font aussi la
comparaison entre ces scènes
d'évacuation auquel on va assister
vraisemblablement en afghanistan avec lé
scène qu'on a pu voir à l'époque lors de
la guerre du vietnam à saigon lorsque
des employés de l'ambassade américaine
avait dû être évacué par hélicoptère
depuis le toit de cette ambassade alors
c'est une comparaison qui avait été
rejetée il y à un mois par joe biden qui
avait affirmé que les deux situations on
n'avait rien à voir mais il ya quand
même toujours des éléments de
comparaison avec cette défaite qui était
finalement assez couru d'avancé le
washington post rappelle dans un
éditorial publié ce vendredi que des
documents qui ont été dévoilées en 2019
par le quotidien américain montrer que
les autorités américaines savaient
qu'elles ne pourraient pas éradiqué de
manière durable la menace des taliban et
ces documents il avait été cachée
pendant longtemps au grand public ici
aux etats unis il faut aussi noter que
les à la presse se montre très critique
contre joe biden contre ce qu'elle
qualifie globalement de la première
grosse erreur diplomatique du président
américain lui qui voulait envoyer un
message fort à l'occasion des 20 ans du
11-septembre et bien finalement il y
aura un symbole inverse avec cette
défaite américaine contre les insurgés
en afghanistan qui pourrait en quelque
sorte galvanisé d'autres mouvements
islamistes dans le monde et on pourrait
craindre aussi en afghanistan un
scénario similaire à ce quizz là ce qui
s'était déroulé en irak en 2011 lorsque
les troupes américaines s'étaient
retirés et qu'elle avait dû se
redéployer quelques années plus tard
face à l'émergence de l'état islamique
merci beaucoup thomas bonnin en direct
de washington
alors comment expliquer cette si rapide
avancée des talibans de quels soutiens
bénéficie-t-il le pakistan est il
derrière leurs offensives décryptage de
younes belle fait la consultant en
relations internationales spécialiste du
monde arabe
les liens étroits et historique contre
eux le talibans et le pakistan sont
aussi très très fort et un pacte
clairement la situation actuellement en
afghanistan donc c'est pour ça que j'ai
dit la géopolitique et les très
importantes je crois qu'on est face à
une nouvelle alliance qui émerge entre
pakistan afghanistan iran est également
la chine la chine qui maintenant on veut
marquer
cette situation comme étant un nouveau
acteur est clairement intéressé 1 par
les matières premières de l'afghanistan
par le fait de faire des liens de
transport entre l'afghanistan l'iran et
le pakistan ce qui permet à la chine
d'avoir un point de fox par rapport à
oudon dans le cadre de cette rivalité
amérique aux chinois mais vraiment face
à une nouvelle crise d'immigration qui
se profile à l horizon suite à ces
drames humanitaires en afghanistan et
qui peuvent impacter les autres pays de
l'asie centrale c'est-à-dire
l'ouzbékistan le tadjikistan et les
autres et les autres pays de cette de
cette région en france situation
sanitaire sans commune mesure aux
antilles pour reprendre les termes du
ministre de la santé en déplacement en
martinique
confinés comme la guadeloupe ont fait le
point des périodes nasa
tout un archipel submergé par la
nouvelle vague épidémique face à la
flambée des cas de coronavirus et à la
saturation de leurs hôpitaux la
martinique et la guadeloupe sont
désormais totalement confinés une
situation sans précédent selon olivier
ferrand en déplacement au chu de fort de
france
le retard pris par la vaccination dans
les antilles françaises ne peut plus
durer d'autant qu'il ya ici des vaccins
pour tout le monde du vaccin fiber c'est
le même bac 5 en métropole même vaccin
que dans la plupart des pays occidentaux
ces vaccins sont sûrs ils sont efficaces
il sauve des vies plus de 4 milliards de
terriens ont d'ores et déjà été
vaccinées par ce vaccin ou par d'autres
difficile de convaincre sur l'île où
seulement 18 % de la population a été
totalement vacciner un seuil bien en
dessous de la moyenne nationale de 51%
le gouvernement compte désormais sur les
élus locaux pour inciter la population à
se faire vacciner
malgré tout le scepticisme des antilles
et demeure
c'est une population qui est méfiante
qui ne va pas tête baissée dans tout ce
qu'on leur dit la question de la
vaccination se pose encore et je crois
que
véritablement dans les outre mer ça sera
ça c'est quelque chose de compliqué ça
sera quelque chose de compliqué c'est
vrai que sur les réseaux sociaux en bois
du tout et du n'importe quoi des fake
news et ça ne ratio pas pour le moment
je ne suis pas vacciné je ne suis pas
contre le vaccin mais je trouve qu'on
n'a pas assez de recul
par rapport à ce barça le défi est donc
de taille pour l'archipel qui tente de
rattraper son retard alors que 274
soignants et 60 pompiers volontaires de
métropole sont partis épauler les
services hospitaliers le gouvernement
promet prochainement des renforts de
renforts
et nous sommes en direct de fort de
france avec and cry cry aux médecins
généralistes présidente de l'union
régionale des médecins libéraux de
martinique
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france vous avez rencontré le ministre
de la santé lors de son déplacement en
martinique que lui avez-vous dit
mais je lui dis que chief allait déjà
mairie à la solidarité nationale parce
que il faut bien se rendre compte que la
martinique fait partie de la france et
merci à toutes et soignants qui sont
venus apporter du renfort à des équipes
hospitalières fatigué j'ai dix personnes
un mot sur billy qu'il fallait pas
oublier les libéraux parce que les
libéraux sont les premiers acteurs sur
le terrain l'hôpital solid 5 % de la
population et 95% sont pris en charge
pas du luberon les infirmiers les
médecins qui sont leurs cabinets qui
sont eux aussi fatigué donc c'est un
travail de tous un travail de vous la
d'exposer dans votre bourse dans votre
reportage il faut convaincre plutôt que
contraindre donc c'est un travail qui
doit se faire à tous les étages par la
proximité par là les verts avec des gens
qui ont confiance donc les messages sont
le premier recours en tant que médecin
généraliste on doit expliquer pourquoi
que se faire vacciner est actuellement
malheureusement nous déplorons
énormément de morts donc pour vous
donner quelques chiffres au 4 juillet de
la martinique déplorait 98 morts de la
coved actuellement au 13 août nous en
sommes à 200 autres aux 12 par dont 210
morts donc vous voyez une explosion plus
de 90% en du 15 juillet au 10 août au 12
août donc nous sommes vraiment eu une
explosion donc je pense que le message à
faire passer c'est que la vaccination
est vite de mourir du coc vite on qu'une
personne qui est actuellement en
réanimation dans les antilles n'a été
vaccinées donc maintenant il ya une
prise de conscience de la population
parce que on écoute vous savez nous dans
les avis de décès on a
tous les jours et elle a la liste
s'allonge devient interminable donc les
personnes connaissent des personnes qui
sont décédées et r nous avons eu à
déplorer
avant-hier le premier médecin décédé
donc il faut vraiment que nous soyons
tous solidaires à chaque à chaque
échelon donc j'ai rasé les week-ends
comme comment je vais vous expliquer la
situation dans laquelle se trouvent les
antilles c'est essentiellement la
conséquence de la de la virulence du
variant delta le ministre de la santé a
déploré le fait et vous l'avez rappelé
que les patients hospitalisés
aujourd'hui ne soit pas plus vaccinée
que vous disent les patients vous
recevez dans votre cabinet pour quelle
raison et ce qu'ils n'ont pas recours à
l'injection nautique au vide
là on a eu une augmentation de plus de
25% la vaccination donc je pense que la
martinique n'a pas été impacté la marque
impacté par la première vague donc là
les gens n'ont pas eu conscience de ce
qui se passe est donc actuellement la
vaccination doit se développer et il ya
une prise de conscience de la population
martiniquaise et de l'impact
qui
les dessins c'est quelque chose qui se
comptabilise donc là maintenant il ya
une prise de conscience de la population
avec en étant effrayé et quand on voit
donc merci à différentes formes ont eu
des militaires nathan nous avons des des
renforts de soignants de l'hexagone et
là on est interrogé par nos patients au
quotidien en disant mais docteur qu'est
ce que vous en pensez ben oui donc quand
on explique actuellement nous sommes
obligés de faire des tris d'hôpital
obligés de faire des tris à l'hôpital de
choix de patients tout sur l'écomobilité
fonction de l'âge ben ça interpelle donc
là il prise de conscience pourquoi elle
n'a pas été fait avant parce qu'on avait
été très peu adapté on allume philo mais
qu'on est dans un autre système moi
avoir à y avait on se sentait pas formés
là la population de santé de pas
forcément concernés le chara relâchement
des gestes barrières peut-être est-ce
que la situation
extrêmement préoccupante aujourd'hui en
martinique et peut-être aussi le
résultat d'un sous-équipement médical
dont souffraient déjà la martinique
non je ne pense pas que ce soit la
conséquence de tout équipement médical
elle a été la conséquence d'une non
vaccination et ensuite on était en
martinique tout au moins on n'était pas
impacté par le virus delta et que le
contamination autochtones par un
relâchement des gestes barrières les
jambes avaient envie voilà de faire la
fête de la musique le de cela chez les
jeunes et la contamination à passer par
les jeunes maintenant la martinique nous
sommes à 50 % des variants delta qui est
beaucoup plus contagieux alors que la
guadeloupe est à plus de 80% du variant
delta donc là nous sommes en phase
exponentielle et ne sommes pas au sommet
de la vague donc que nous y serons dans
quinze jours et le le missel outre-mer
le ministre de la santé aura pris tous
les deux tons sony's de la santé puisque
c'est de sa compétence en disant que
j'aurais un roulement dans les écrits de
la première équipe de grand soir est
arrivé pour 15 jours et on va avoir une
seconde équipe est ce que j'ai demandé
au ministre était de s'occuper aussi les
libérons qui sont épuisés
bon pour avoir à un renfort en mai qui
libéral pour pouvoir avoir des relais on
qui dans les cabinets médicaux de
radiologie de médecins généralistes
d'avoir des renforts parce qu'on ne leur
a besoin actuellement les renforts sont
sur l'hôpital et on a entrant à
l'hôpital est en train d'armer plusieurs
lits de réanimation avec l'hôpital du
carbet qui va fermer l'hôpital du marin
qui est en magasin de l'autre aux
hôpitaux et il ya de la formation je
voulais vous portez c'est que ça me dit
il va y avoir une évacuation sanitaire
de patients vers la métropole avec six
patients qui vont partir vers l'hexagone
merci beaucoup d'avoir prétend
de réagir sur notre antenne même creek
et ayo je rappelle que vous êtes médecin
présidente de l'union régionale des
médecins libéraux de martinique
en métropole hospitalisation et
réanimation continue de progresser les
plans blancs pour renforcer les
personnels des hôpitaux ont été
déclenchés sur le pourtour méditerranéen
en corse et sur la façade atlantique des
landes ychoux obligations présentées le
pass année terre dans les grands centres
commerciaux de huit départements où ce
taux d'incidence est préoccupant un
sésame que certains maires ont décidé de
ne pas faire contrôler dans leur commune
par leur police municipale
un tel refus est il légal les
explications de guy marrot 6 hayange en
moselle villeneuve loubet dans les
alpes-maritimes à béziers et à vias dans
l'hérault à beaucaire dans le gard dans
toutes ces villes les maires l'ont dit
ils ne participeront pas au contrôle du
pass sanitaires dont les bars et les
restaurants à fréjus par exemple c'est
l'édile david rachline qui s'est élevé
contre cette disposition en publiant
mardi une tribune dans valeurs actuelles
il est revenu sur les raisons de son
choix sur notre antenne regarder je ne
souhaite pas que la police municipale ne
ferai juste participent à ce flicage
généralisé en réalité ce monde en tout
cas ce pays ou dans lequel tous ceux va
être vont être surveillés par des
policiers par des gérants de restaurants
tout cela n'est pas acceptable la
priorité elle est claire c'est la lutte
contre la délinquance contre les vols
contre pour l'ordre public de manière
générale et certainement pas ce flicage
alors se pose tout de même une question
ses locaux ont-ils le droit de ne pas
faire contrôler le pass sanitaire parce
que si le maire agit au nom de la
commune il exerce également des pouvoirs
au nom de l'état selon le code général
des collectivités territoriales le maire
est chargé de la police municipale sous
le contrôle du préfet il est aussi
chargé toujours sous l'autorité du
préfet de l'exécution des mesures de
sûreté générale et les mesures de lutte
contre la pandémie dont le pass
sanitaire rentre clairement dans ce
cadre là la police municipale est par
ailleurs bien habilité à procéder à des
contrôles dupas sanitaires comme le
prévoit le code de la santé publique du
coup à tous ces maires qui demandent à
leurs agents municipaux de ne pas
contrôler le pass sanitaires on pourrait
leur reprocher de manquer à leurs
obligations et de ne pas faire appliquer
les lois de la république ces édiles et
pourrait même être suspendue c'est une
mesure extrême mais c'est déjà arrivé
par le passé sauf qu'en réalité rien de
tout cela ne se produira tout simplement
parce que eh bien les maires ont toute
compétence pour décider des missions
qu'ils confient à leur police municipale
deux types de règles pourraient nous en
empêcher une interdiction claire dans
une loi ou un décret ou une contre
indication du préfet or nous n'avons vu
ni l'un ni l'autre et justement aucune
injonction précise n'a été formulée par
l'état le ministère de l'intérieur
confirme d'ailleurs que si les agents de
police municipale sont bien habilité à
procéder à des contrôles du pass
sanitaires rien ne les y oblige idem du
côté des préfectures qui pour le moment
n'ont pris aucune décision contraignante
vis-à-vis des mères la préfecture a
toujours mentionné qu'il s'agissait
d'une possibilité mais il n'est fait
nulle part mention d'une quelconque
obligation cela n'a pas empêché la
préfecture du var de condamner la
position du maire de fréjus décrite
comme je cite une manoeuvre politicienne
conclusion rien n'oblige les élus locaux
à demander à leur police de contrôler
les passes sanitaire cela dit ça ne
devrait pas changer grand chose pour les
administrés des communes réfractaires
qui reste contrôlable par la police
nationale et n'oublions pas que les
restaurateurs restent soumis à
l'obligation de contrôler les passes
sanitaires car oui nous sommes désormais
dans une situation où des citoyens sont
davantage tenu de faire respecter la loi
que certains policiers les policiers qui
eux à la différence des restaurateurs
n'ont pas à présenter de pas sanitaires
pour être autorisés à travailler
le conseil constitutionnel valide
l'essentiel du projet de loi concernant
la lutte contre le séparatisme un texte
controversé adopté définitivement par le
parlement le 23 juillet dernier saisi
par des parlementaires de gauche et de
droite les sages ont rendu en fin de
journée leur décision les détails avec
notre reporter d'un déchet 5
sans surprise le conseil constitutionnel
a donc validé l essentiel du projet de
loi controversé sur le séparatisme un
texte définitivement adopté par le
parlement le 23 juillet dernier après
sept mois de débats houleux à
l'assemblée nationale comme au sénat
elle saisi par des députés et sénateurs
de droite comme de gauche est les sages
n'ont censuré que deux mesures la
première au sujet est des dissolutions
d'associations
écoutez ce qu'en dit le conseil
constitutionnel
en permettant au ministre de l'intérieur
de prendre une telle décision pour une
durée pouvant atteindre six mois dans
l'attenté d'une décision de dissolution
ces dispositions pour objet de suspendre
les activités d'une association dont il
n'est pas encore établi quels troubles
gravement l'ordre public il résulte
d'ailleurs des travaux préparatoires que
cette décision de suspension vise à
permettre aux autorités compétentes de
disposer du temps nécessaire à
l'instruction du dossier de dissolution
dès lors en permettant de prendre une
telle décision sans autre condition que
l'urgence le législateur a porté à la
liberté d'association une atteinte qui
n'est pas nécessaire adaptées et
proportionnées autre mesure censuré par
les sages celle sur les retraits de
titre de séjour accordés aux étrangers
en cas de rejet des principes de la
république
le conseil constitutionnel a estimé que
les termes du projet de loi ne
permettait pas je cite de déterminer
avec suffisamment de précision les
comportements justifiant le retrait le
non renouvellement ou encore la non
délivrance d'un titre de séjour à un
étranger de mesures censuré mais qui ne
porte pas sur des dispositions majeures
sur twitter gérald darmanin à l'origine
de ce projet de loi elle s'est félicitée
de sa validation par le conseil
constitutionnel
excellente nouvelle pour la république
nous nous félicitons avec marlène
schiappa de la validation par le conseil
constitutionnel de la loi séparatisme ce
texte voulu par emmanuel macron
permettra de lutter avec force grâce à
de nouvelles armes contre ceux qui
veulent porter atteinte à la laïcité
notre bien commun ce texte a dès sa
présentation suscité la polémique dans
la sphère politique mais aussi et
surtout aux prêts
la société civile et des communautés
religieuses et pour cause beaucoup
s'accordent à dire en effet que le texte
s'attaquerait aux équilibres de la loi
de 1905 et qu'il porte atteinte aux
libertés de culte d'associations et
d'opinion
en algérie les feux de forêt sont en
passe d'être maîtrisé ils ravagent la
kabylie depuis lundi au moins 71
personnes ont trouvé la mort des feux en
majeure partie d'origine criminelle
selon les autorités vingt deux suspects
ont été arrêtés les flammes ont dévasté
des villages entiers
la solidarité s'organise grâce
d'ailleurs
les forêts de kabylie toujours la proie
des flammes les incendies persistent et
avec eux le besoin de trouver des
coupables à une telle catastrophe
hier le président abdel majid tebboune a
annoncé l'arrestation de 22 suspects si
les fortes chaleurs sont en cause pour
lui la majorité des incendies sont
d'origine criminelle
le président a également demandé à ses
amis européens de lui prêter main forte
la france a envoyé ce jeudi deux
canadair et sera suivie de l'espagne et
de la suisse s'il est sur le terrain est
essentielle l'aide à la population est
également que ce soit la diaspora en
france ou sur place aux quatre coins de
l'algérie la mobilisation est forte ici
à tizi ouzou les associations
réceptionne les colis dead fois c'était
vraiment exceptionnel nous avons
énormément donné
mais aussi beaucoup de volontaires
beaucoup de personnes qui nous
contactent
du matin au soir on reçoit deux appels
couple pour donner les devants pour
venir aider pour demander quoi faire
après les gens sont perdus
c'est un décor d'apocalypse que mokrane
trouve à la place de sa maison qu'il a
dû fuir quand les incendies ont démarré
quand nous avons vu le feu s'approcher
de nous nous avons évacué la famille et
les jeunes enfants nous avons attendu
longtemps dehors devant la maison mon
frère et moi avons essayé d'éteindre le
feu ici mais nous n'avons pas réussi car
le feu est entré de l'autre côté de la
maison par la fenêtre tous les meubles
de la maison et son contenu ont pris feu
et ont été détruits
chaque année le nord du pays est en
proie à des feux de forêt mais cette
fois à l'instar de la turquie ou de la
grèce le phénomène s'amplifie avec les
vagues de chaleur les esprits d'une
population désemparée s'échauffent à
miliana un jeune homme a été lynché
avant d'être tuée et immolé par une
foule l'accusant d'être pyromanes
le président abdel majid tebboune
appelle les algériens à l'unité
nationale
et c'est la fin de cette édition
prochain point sur l'actuelle dans une
trentaine de minutes à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne